foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Petersburg uncensored it was
the bombshell interview that drove
Cristiano Ronaldo out of Manchester
United and may have also driven out the
club's owners and much despised glazes
here are some of the highlights from
that interview
[Music]
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored welcome to the special
edition of Piers Morgan on Center cinema
next hour Cristiano Ronaldo turns up the
heat his sensationally reveals he has no
respect for his current manager he calls
out Manchester United's owners the
glazers he talks candidly about his
future at Old Trafford and the World Cup
and Qatar he even reveals his retirement
plans and what do you think civilian or
Messi
do you have more pounds in the bank or
more Instagram followers
it's a good question
probably similar I don't know
probably similar I'm just trying to work
out how Wayne Rooney could hate you even
more and probably that's the answer well
not only him imagine the rest of the
rats they're gonna criticize you too
but it's good it's good to be still
number one if you you see the make
something that make me happy too if you
see Forbes Magazine every year I'm in
the top of the list so it's not by
coincidence too but knowing you I don't
it's not the money so much it's just you
want to be at the top right I mean
that's what I think what drives you
someone said to me what drives Cristiano
Ronaldo I don't think it's money I think
it's being the best
beating people it's a competitive streak
the the records the adrenaline but
Pierce let's let's let's be uh honest
the last years the football change
I see football now as a business to be
honest
sometimes the Georgian have expression
that I don't understand they treat you
they treat you players like a piece of
meat and say yes you say everything is
true when they want you when they they
they they count with you they give you
everything when they don't they try to
to make a hard life to you
I see football piece the last years as a
business I saw many many things that I'm
disappointing the passion for the game
is still intact but in the same way I
say I saw other things as well
which is
surprised me but in the same way it's
part of the business because
if you see the world how it is in the
moment it's it's all business everyone
take on itself everyone they are more
individual well you become a commodity
Danny where if you can sell record
number of shirts in 24 hours great right
but if suddenly the team isn't
performing well they need someone to
blame it looks to me like at Manchester
United the default position is it's got
to be Cristiano's fault exactly it's
always always my fault the problem is
always me I look like I'm the black
sheep which is I don't like if you do it
good or if you do bad they all is going
to find some some criticize even in the
national team the last three months as I
told you before they criticize was so
bad I mean not only in football way but
professional
and family way as well which surprised
me a lot
looked like I was a bad guy which is not
true people have to listen
from my mouth the real the facts as well
this is why I give this interview
because I thought I I think it's the the
right time to speak out of my my mind
which is what they say the last four or
five months is completely garbage I'm
not gonna say 100 but 99 it was garbage
people say false things are alive things
which things have annoyed you the most
family issues
um well I want to talk about one in
particular on that which is when you
were late back for the pre-season
training a lot of speculation because
you'd said several weeks before that you
wanted to play Champions League football
and that you were maybe looking for
another option because it didn't look
like United would get to play Let's make
my points for example the preseason
moment and after you mentioned uh
new clubs or interesting for example the
preseason I had a very very bad
which is I don't say nobody the people
who surround me they saw friends and
even my mom I had some problems in
vacation that my young daughter they
have a little problem they have brown
kids which is she's still conscious
bronchitis yes yes your little baby yes
I was in Majorca and holidays and sister
one week in hospital
which is was
you know you don't enjoy a lot and after
what had happened so well exactly and
the people make make up histories that
they say that I don't want to go travel
because they people have to understand
that I'm a human being I'm always going
to be in my side of my family
I'm not negotiate nothing
behind that you understand
and I even have the the lectures of from
the hospital the the feedback of the
health of Bella which is I'm not sure
nobody nobody asked me I have I keep for
me people forget that I'm human human
being that I passed through a difficult
moments
well you must have been worried sick I
mean you I was very Warrior now your
baby daughter's in hospital exactly and
you must have been absolutely a software
directive of
and the president of Manchester United
and then
kind of that didn't believe
that something going wrong which is make
me feel bad really yes I am yes I didn't
believe you
they believe you but in the same way
they are there and never is Ever Gonna
Change
the health of my family
for the football never
now or
10 years
behind or forwards and it's something
that really hurt me because they doubt
of my words that I struggle especially
Bell and Geo we had one week in hospital
because the Bell have a big problem
and I didn't go to the preseason because
of that because I didn't I didn't
was allowed to left my family if
something happened
to do it the Precision because I think
it wasn't not fair to left my family for
a preseason this is why I didn't go
I mean that would if my employer didn't
believe a story like that that would
I would be so angry
because everyone I'm not mentioned only
in that in that
Manchester way but in the world
especially in the football world
they are very very very individual
everyone everyone on look for on selves
or themselves they don't care about
your moments your struggle moments your
issues family problems
they want you they want you doesn't
matter
your family problems I don't mean
Manchester but in a general
as I told you before the football goes
so fast you have many competition many
games prices and World Cup now listen we
have last you have one game after three
four days you have to be in the national
team preparation for the World Cup it's
hard sometimes you have to sell
everything and you know
be with your family
take the best decisions and
in this summer I didn't feel comfortable
I feel uncomfortable the way they treat
me especially the the Press they doubt
about me the professional that I am
it's impossible to be 21 in the top of
the game if you're not professional they
doubt about me which is make me feel
very very very sad because in my life
I'm always one of the best professional
this is why I still play in that level
you play in a pre-season friendly and
you leave the ground early with several
other players and there's another huge
fuss about this
what was the truth about that had you
got permission to go do you wish you
hadn't left early now Trent Harmon
wasn't happy it was reported what's the
truth
because um I'll I will be honest with
you
um
is something that I regret to left from
the stadium probably or maybe no I don't
know it's difficult to
tell you 100 percent
if I'm
but let's say I regret
but in the same way I felt provoked by
the coach I'm not allowed for me
a coach to put me in three minutes in
the game Sorry I'm not that kind of
player I know what I can give to the
teams you're talking about the Tottenham
thing the Tottenham yeah I'm talking
about in pre-season it was a friendly
where you left the ground with a several
millions and eight players right so that
they mention only my name yeah which is
everyone do that
I don't understand why they mentioned
only about about high value kind of play
game
last year many players do it the same in
that game eight players do it the same
so but they only speak about the black
Chip which is me which is I completely
understand okay it's done I apologize to
the coach and for me
the chapter was was closed
forced out to Manchester United
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wanted to show you who the boss was
that he dropped you he benched you
he mucked you around
he talked about you in the Press
were you getting that feeling I mean did
you feel that the feeling he always
mentioned to me that I didn't need the
preseason so I should wait for my
opportunity I really understand I should
well okay I understand
but I'm not gonna give you
points but
it don't do it the same precedent from
to every players I'm not gonna mention
players but they don't do it the same
way
second I understand that
becoming a new job Manchester was so bad
the last five years that it should make
they should clean the house let's say in
that way
but the way they approach the way the
Press make this so big it's because
probably the
the communication wasn't the best
uh um but I I really understand in the
beginning because I didn't do the
preseason I don't stop to play but going
more further than that further than that
other things happen that people they
don't know
and I'm not I'm not uh hiding that the
empathy with the coach is not good I'm
I'm honest you don't have a good
relationship with him I'm not mean good
relationship the empathy is not it's not
good let's say do you think he respects
you
I think you don't you don't respect the
way I should deserve
um
but
it is what it is this is why probably
the the game against Tottenham well I've
only come to these two games so against
Manchester City where United got
destroyed
he didn't bring you on he brought
another Strikers but didn't bring you on
and
I felt insulted on your behalf I was
like well surely against Manchester City
if you're losing this badly and you've
got the greatest player of all time
sitting there you at least give him some
time don't you but he didn't and he said
afterwards the reason was he had too
much respect for he wanted to respect
you when you heard him say that what did
you think
excuses
I see as excuses
um I sell many things that
I don't wanna I don't want to criticize
him it can it can have different opinion
than me that they choose the players
that I think is better for the team I
respect that but the excuse is all the
time you know excuses have short legs
you cannot excuse all the time which is
things that don't make sense okay you
don't put me against Manchester City
because of respect of your career and
you want to put me three minutes against
daughter well that's the thing so then
you then play Tottenham don't make sense
and then he wants to bring you on with
three minutes to go which is the
complete opposite to what he said the
situation was with City I think it did
it did it did purpose because for
example in the national team the other
clubs if the coach want to put me five
minutes if someone injured or or if they
really need me I will help but in that
way I felt provoked not only because of
that game but before he was deliberately
provoking him nice for everyone everyone
know that disrespecting you think
exactly this is why I say I don't have
respect for him because they don't show
me respect for me this is why
we we are we are in that situation I
have to be I have to be honest that the
things done going well because of that
because the empathy don't exists and it
keeps it keeps say things for the Press
but the Press
say what they think it's it's it's good
to protect probably him and Manchester
United but
as I know as I understand many things
that is signed three years contract with
Manchester United probably I'm not going
to be too much longer in Manchester
United apart when I'm finished my
contract I really understand but I like
guys that they don't like they speak
honest they beat frotel frontal and I'm
not going to negotiate my morals my
morals always will be intact and what
what's going in my in my in my things
the last two months was
um not respect in many ways
which is it I can regret for example
against Tottenham to left the stadium
before uh the Finish Well there's a
video clip which appears to show ten
Hart telling you to get ready to come on
and you gesticulate back to him I'm not
going to do that and as a result you get
suspended for the next couple of games
and he goes public and says this because
he refused to come on and you did then
issue a statement of some regret saying
you know you're a professional and
you've never been suspended before I
don't think never entire career I mean
when you look back at that I guess my
question would be you've always been
very acutely aware of Your Role Model
status around the world
do you wish with hindsight you hadn't
done that and handled it I regret to
left the stadium yeah but I was as I
told appears before I didn't felt that
he had a respect for me to put me on
three minutes after the issues that we
had before
um
I was very very very very disappointing
for
the communicate of Manchester United to
be honest I never had a problem with any
club with any coach
and they suspending three days which is
I felt a lot and it was
and and level of sport clubs I felt a
lot and it was a shame humiliating I
think so yes I have to to say the truth
what I felt I remember I arrived I I
arrived
well I don't want to say I don't want to
say details what it pretend to do it but
I'm not going to say that but I remember
arriving home and Christiana see me that
they did not go to the game and say no
because
the club punished me with three days and
he did like
oh they're gonna punish you if you are
the best player in the world and uh
you're not gonna play you say no I'm not
gonna play because I I'm not being I'm
behave and you look at me like my dad
did not behave what
in one way I was
good because I was like more relaxed but
in the same way I feel very disappointed
because
okay I regret I apologize I'm not
perfect I commit a mistake but to
suspending three games three days
for that I think it's too much and they
they make fire for the Press which is
really disappointment and that seems to
have been the pattern of the way ten
Hargis wanted to treat you since he
became manager just constant
attempt to disrespect you I guess
many many points happen
I think in some certain points I think
was strategy
from the club for me to react like that
because they wanted you to leave
probably yes they're trying to force you
out yes not only the coach but the other
two or three guys there around
the club
at the senior executive level yes that I
felt betrayed
and you think they're trying to get rid
of you
honestly I shouldn't say that I don't
know but listen I I don't care I'm
always people should listen the truth
yes I feel betrayed and I felt that some
people that don't want me here not only
this year but last year too
they didn't want you to go there at all
no really yes
the owners of the club they listen they
don't the glazes the glazes they don't
they don't care about about the club I
mean
professional uh
sport
as you know this Manchester is a
marketing Club they will get
his money from the marketing
the sports
it's that that don't really care in my
opinion you ever talk to them the glazes
never never not since you've gone back
no they give all the power to the
president the sport directive
a lot of Manchester United fans
are very negative about the glazes they
think they're taking all the money out
and are spending enough on players on
the infrastructure issues he talked
about do you think the fans are right
the fans are they're always right I
think the fans should know the true
should know that
the place we want the best for the club
I want the best of the club this is why
you're coming to Manchester United this
is why I love this club
but you have some
things inside the club which is don't
help
to Manchester reach the top level as
City Liverpool and even now Arsenal for
example
which is complicated it's difficult
um
it's hard in my opinion it will be hard
for Manchester to be in the top of the
game
the next two three years the Glazer
stays on us I'm not mean the glazes but
the structure this structure
um as
as Picasso say you have to destroy it to
rebuild and if they can start from me
I'm for me is not a problem I'm all is
what I'm gonna say I love Manchester
United I love defense they're always on
my side
but if they want to do it different era
different generation they have to change
many many things
when you walked away at Spurs and didn't
go on Gary Neville said your behavior
was unacceptable called for you to be
punished he said he knows what he's
doing he's experienced and players of
that power have a real negative impact
when they do it the influence they have
on other players is really negative
and it's after that you gave them your
blank treatment which was very funny by
the way
um
but for Neville to say that about you
they can't they can't they only they
don't see the big picture
why I react like that what's happened
all the behind the scenes all the behind
the scenes I was
probably not provoke
they will accept to play three minutes
after all situations that going through
the last two months
don't tell me that top players the guys
want everything the key players
will play three minutes come on this is
unacceptable after what
they keep saying before that they
respect me they do this they do that
for me it wasn't not respect this is why
I take this decision I regret I've
I apologize to my teammates for the
situation I did a post
and Instagram I regret to left from the
stadium
I regret my teammates they know what I
felt I said to them apologize but in the
same way I'm not regret to take the
decisions to done coming on I'm like
that I will be always like that if you
don't have respect for me I'm not going
to have respect for you and the coach
didn't have respect for me so this is
why
the relationship it's it's in that way
and it keeps saying in a press that he
can't with me like me but it's only for
the Press really yes 100
so where are you now in your head with
all this because the World Cup is about
to start you're going to go there with
Portugal and we'll talk about that in a
moment with a very exciting team
actually
um but where are you with United they
won't be playing again now until after
Christmas that leaves a few days before
the January transfer window do you think
you'll still be a United player come
January 1st it's difficult to tell her
right now because we my moods is right
now
to the World Cup it's probably my last
World Cup of course my fifth World Cup
I don't know what's going to happen
um
after the World Cup but as I told you
before and I will say again
the funds will be always in my heart and
I hope they
've been in my side
even if I'm back or if I'm not back or
if I stay or whatever
nobody's perfect episodes in the life we
all have uh is part of
the human beings is part of me to be a
human being and father as well
I always will commit a mistakes
uh uh but I don't know it's hard to tell
you right now what's going to happen the
World Cup because my focus is only for
the World Cup for the Portugal national
team
coming next well Ronaldo still be Old
Trafford after the World Cup I'll ask
him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
if you had your time again knowing what
was going to happen
would you sign for Manchester United
again
as I told in the beginning I'm always
took my decisions by
not
emotional moments but maybe this
this decision I took by emotional
I'm not regret
uh because I took with 100 conscience
but it was more emotional than rational
I don't know if it's no sense
but it was good was good because
I was happy
when they left me be happy
so I tried to give my advices my
experience
to help Manchester United to be where
they deserve to be
um
I don't pretend to be more smart than
the other ones nobody is smarter than me
but I'm not smarter than nobody
when I arrive in Manchester United I
always be available to help the team to
do the good things to put in the right
spots
to compete with the best teams
but it's hard when they they cut your
legs and that they don't like you to
shine on they don't listen your advices
I think I I have Awards to advice to the
club because the trophies that I won
individual and Collective I think I can
help a lot but when the infrastructure
is not
good what's amazing is you ended last
season
with hat tricks you're scoring hat
tricks for fun one against Tottenham
you know you were playing great football
but you were starting most games and now
this season you barely started any game
something happened you know I'd imagine
you're a bit like a racehorse right if
you don't start I didn't do depressed
season right right is there is the
excuse right which is the preseason so
you think if you've been able to just do
what you did last season you just got
carried on scoring for sure you think I
I just learned
to score goals maybe I'm not motivated
that I'm supposed to be probably as I
told you before because I'm human being
I feel the things
I'm not perfect
but my motivation is not the same that I
was that I was
a few months ago
and I hope to change do you feel like
you need a fresh challenge
I'd say if it's fresh fresh challenge
but let's say let's see I'm not I cannot
answer right now because my focus is for
the World Cup
but I don't know maybe it's good for
Manchester and berries and probably is
good for me as well
to have a new chapter probably but I
don't know if if I will be back I will
be the same Cristiano but I hope people
being on my side and let me shine like I
did
all the clubs and all ears what is the
truth about other clubs making offers
for you some people have said there were
no offers at all I happened to know that
there was a gigantic one from Saudi
Arabia for example 350 million euros for
two seasons is that okay yes it's true
that's a staggering sum of money yes
which you turned out in that moment yes
I mean that to me says you're not just
about the money this is what it's what
I'm gonna mention now it's they say many
many garbage thing that
if you are Urgent what you're going to
do you go the clubs but George Mendes
for example have more than 100 players
and they go Chelsea they go Arsenal they
always mention Cristiano Ronaldo they
offer Cristiano base let's be honest
who's the most expensive player salary
player that
Premier League have in history it's me
even with 37 years old why they're gonna
even they even offer me
to sporting uh Annapolis I will be
honest with you you don't I didn't have
many many clubs but I have many many
offers of the other clubs which is I
didn't change because I didn't plan to
do it but I have but what the Press
keeping say and the garbage price say
that nobody want me which is completely
wrong
and I was happy here to be honest I was
motivated to do it a great season here
but but they continue to repeat nobody
won Cristiano how how they don't want to
play to last year's got 32 goals
with national team I mean that's the
point I don't get because there are
people out there and you see them you
hear them
and they say well he's not the player he
used to be as if somehow at 37 you're
going to be as good as you were at 21.
anyway everyone change but you are the
greatest 37 year old anyone's ever seen
right and you're still extremely fit so
it just seems to me nothing's changed
from the player I saw banging in hat
tricks last season except that you have
a coach who doesn't want to start you a
few months or what they're going to
change there's nothing
because I feel like you can still be a
top player but for me it's it's it's
it's stupid questions when people say ah
they are not the same nobody is the same
day by day we're getting old every one
of us you understand it's normal you
have to adapt and I think nobody in this
game
have this brain that adapts with his age
I'm not I'm not want to be cocky to say
that I'm the same that when I asked 20
of course no but I'm adopt and I be
smart to know my strength what I'm good
to do and I'm still playing the higher
level and I score goals and I will
continue to score goals if my mind is
clear and happy and if the people
surround me there help me to be
successful player especially the coach
president directives but when you feel
that the energy don't go surround you
it's difficult you to be yourself which
is happening this is what's happened
with me but what they say the last three
months is completely garbage and wrong
they say that I offer me this and that
and many presidents and directives speak
about their reject from it it's
completely lie they'll lie because he's
is is not what's happened I had many
clubs not many a few clubs that they
want me to sign and I didn't go because
I feel comfortable here this is the
truth how easy is it to turn down 350
million pounds to kick a football for
two years in Saudi Arabia it's hard it's
hard it's hard but in the same way I I
thought that I was very happy here that
I still capable to score goals and make
people up is it also that you want to
keep playing at the highest level that
you want to play Champions League
Football you want to keep breaking
records is it again it comes back to my
gut feeling about you that if it was
just about money you would be you'd be
in Saudi Arabia right earning this
king's Ransom but you that's not what
motivates you you want to keep exactly
because I thought I I still believe that
I can't score many many goals and helped
the team because I I still believe that
I'm I'm still good and capable to help
national team even Manchester United but
if you don't feel surround you that the
energies is in in your side it's
difficult of course the criticize we're
gonna exists all the time all right 37
is still not the same but I want to see
if some guy of my heads maintained the
level that I that I show you're not
gonna teach me that nobody gonna teach
me I know he was fit as you've ever been
do you think yes yes in this moment I
feel very very good I believe that I'm
gonna do it Amazing World Cup
and prepare physically and mentally
but
peace is it it is what it is life is
good I'm good my mental is good I'm
happy to do this entire video I know
they're gonna generate very polemic of
course but Christianity they would
anyway right I mean they've all had
their say and now you're entitled to
have your say and you know better than
anybody because you are Cristiano
Ronaldo they criticize me when I don't
speak of course when I'm gonna speak the
according to criticize me even more but
it's something that I can I can deal
with that I know I'm gonna disappointing
a few people maybe I'm gonna make up a
few people but it is what it is the life
is it's completely
difficult we have obstacles in our lives
and uh
I will keep running to fight against the
people who don't believe me and the life
is a challenge and I wanted people the
people that they are wrong when they say
that if you do leave United and I accept
this is not a done decision either way
but if you do and it seems to me like
that's more likely than not as we sit
here
what would your message be to Manchester
United fans who've had to
read all this stuff all year and
probably have a very mixed idea about
where the truth lies what would you say
to them if you do end up leaving
it's hard it's hard for me to say that I
will not be back to Manchester United
but regardless as you say it's it's
let's see what's going to happen
but as I told you before the fans for me
always will be in my side will be always
in my heart I see during the days when I
go to the street to love the passion
that people have for me
um the respect
I hope that they never forget
the things that I will continue to do it
not only in the past but in the present
too Manchester will be always in my side
defense will be always in my side
doesn't matter what's going to happen
and I appreciate the loves that they
send for me all the time even when I'm
done play we even when they when they
criticize me the always will be in my
heart so thank you to Dollar supports
hope to see you soon and uh they always
will be in my heart
and what about Ceramics the man who
persuaded you to come back again
really like a father figure to you
really in many ways like another another
father to you
what's his
take on everything that's been happening
what's his opinion of all this
I don't speak with him like one month
ago but it's always on my side you
always understand me he knows that he
knows better than nobody that the club
is not on the path that deserves to be
he knows everyone knows the people who
don't see that is because they don't
want to see they are blame
the fans
they are always
the answer
and the passion for the game Manchester
belonged to defense but they should know
the true the infrastructure they are not
good they should change if not
Manchester is not going to be where
there used to be what when Sarah Alex
Ferguson David Gill was and out to be
part if they count with me to help the
club
to be successful if not the life will
continue I will continue to my journey I
will continue to make fans happy and
score goals and do it tricks and
everything and
um it's good it's part of my journey
thanks Ronaldo and Leo and the World Cup
in Qatar
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
briefly about the World Cup
um your fifth World Cup and you say it's
your last but I mean you'd only be 41 at
the next one could we have a sixth World
Cup potentially will be tough
will be tough so this may be the last
one probably yes you've got an exciting
team full of experience and young
players Portugal are you optimistic
about your very optimistic we have a
fantastic coach we have a good
generation of football players
I'm looking forward that we're going to
do an amazing world cup would that be
for you the the Pinnacle of your career
to win a world cup with Portugal Please
add on I don't
I never well I dream one time about that
holding the World Cup yes
it's gonna be tough extremely difficult
but everything is possible but
of course we're gonna compete it's hard
to beat who are the who are the biggest
Rivals we are not the favorites
no of course but who do you weren't
famous when you won the exactly exactly
who do you think are the ones to really
watch who are the best squads out there
probably France
France
I will put Spain Argentina Germany
Brazil Brazil of course they look good
to me they look good what about you
haven't mentioned them ah England as
well yeah yeah of course England you
think England have a have a chance I
have a chance beside Portugal in my
opinion
uh
uh but let's see will be different
will be in a winter is it weird playing
at winter do you care do you care
don't really care to be honest a part of
the issue is that the country wherever
they try to
they try to speak now that it wasn't not
good option to do there but they should
do that before we should focus only in
football the competition to people to
enjoy you think all the politics and the
morality debates and stuff should that
all be left aside now 100 focus on the
on the games I feel that of course they
should though they should do that that
debate should be had before you award
exactly exactly they should concentrate
it in in all competition all the
national teams the people to be welcome
in a in a in Qatar and I I see I see a
good tournament to be honest I think
Qatar they are prepared they are
prepared for that and will be where to
play in the beginning of the Season yes
but in the same way a challenge I think
it's to be honest it's good I feel good
I feel with good energy so what about
this idea you get to the final
Portugal the Argentina
you scored two messy scores two
the last minute 94th minute
you score a third for your hat trick and
you win the World Cup is that be honest
still good is that the dream it's too
good I didn't expect that two good dream
but if it happened
ah come on
that's the you can scale you can score
another player I don't care I don't care
if the Portugal being a final in score
even the goalkeeper I will be the most
happy man in the world but if if this
happened come on
I will say I will finish football if
this happened
all right yeah yeah I'll retired 100
I mean it may well be Messi's last World
Cup
he's never won it either I mean you are
you know you're linked forever the pair
of you to me the greatest there's ever
been
you're number one for me uh thank you
he's number two you're number one to you
leave number two
um but it's an amazing relationship you
have even though you're not I know great
friends or anything but you're always
respectful when you see each other what
do you think of him Messina as you both
head to maybe your last work as a
football player yeah and as a person
amazing player is Magic top
as a person we share the state
16 years imagine 16 years
we are the highest we share so I have
great relationship with him I'm not
friend of him in terms of when I mean
friend is the guy who is with you in
your house speaking the phone no but
it's like a teammate he's a guy that I
really respect the way he always speak
about me
even his wife or my wife my girlfriend
they always respect and they're from
Argentina my girlfriend is from
Argentina so good what I'm gonna say
about Mexico things he's a good guy is
you do everything for football the best
player you've ever seen excluding
yourself
probably yes
um
zidane probably
yes that I
play fight with him yes have you ever
had dinner together never would you like
to why not one day to sit down and yes
listen I I like it can I come I love of
course I love to meet people I love
people you know I like I love to share
things ideas learn things ideas new
histories New Brains why not
I will do it for sure I will do it that
would be in a few years yeah at the bats
as Maradona and Pele did yes
no problem come on I'm a good person I
know I've I have a good heart and you
know I'm
I don't like I don't like to you know to
criticize people it's not the way I I
took my life everything is positive and
it's like a weird sequence of events and
papay goes to Real Madrid and PSG ring
you up and go we've had a great idea we
want to put Messi and Ronaldo everything
it's everything it's possible in in
football so and that would be incredible
why not I don't know I don't know as I
told you before they sell some shirts
for sure for sure for sure they will
sell a lot of shirts we're also going to
win the Premier League I hope so you do
Manchester first if not if not Arsenal
is some team that I like to see to play
did you rate the team at the moment yes
I do I like the team I like the coach I
think they do it a good team and uh if
Manchester United don't win the Premier
League I will be happy if Arsenal do
what would you like your legacy to be
Christian I mean well let me ask you
first do you have any plans to retire I
mean how long do you think you can keep
playing football I want to play two
years more three years more two three
years my Maximo I want to play with
when I finish with 40. I think we'll be
a 40 40.
a good age but I don't know I don't know
the future sometimes you plan you plan
one thing for your life and as I told
many times the life is the dynamic and
you never know what's going to happen
Tom Brady in America the great NFL
quarterback retired
then he has a conversation with you on
the Old Trafford pitch and whatever you
said to him I'm psychology so the next
day he comes out of retirement
psychology see I'm good psychologist
what did you say no I thought I thought
it it took the decision a few weeks
before
uh but it was good what did you talk
about you two guys speak about in
general is very very smart guy and and
he's called a hat trick that did it yes
I did he give me good energy when I have
good and good energy and you have
another goat in the stadium does that
fire you up exactly goat thing right yes
yes it's energies it's all about energy
when you are when you have good energy
around you
I can be interesting things
what about Jordan Peterson who I know
came to see you amazing man yeah because
I've interviewed him a few times and he
was fascinated to meet you and to talk
to you both about private things about
what had happened to your family this
year but also about professionally you
and your situation
I'm a huge fan of him I I read his book
12 rules
and I felt that is really really
interesting guy and I love to meet smart
people and uh fantastic men and I
learned a lot some advices that he gave
me
not only what was the best advice he
gave you
we have a nice strategic conversation
not only for the moment of my life I
mean not only for football because my
life is not resume only for football I
have I'm a businessman I've you know and
many important things on my life and
when you are surrounded with these
people for with you as well people that
make your life more interesting they
reach something in your daily life I
appreciate because
it's that kind of people that thinking
outside the box which is I I appreciate
and we had a nice conversation strategic
conversation not only for the moment but
for the future as well you give him some
points that I never expect but
the beginning was to meet him a good
person an intelligent person and uh was
fantastic and I we keep in touch I speak
with him it's good
you're going to do Cristiano Ronaldo's
12 rules to life why not for the future
maybe more rules exactly for the future
probably I wanna I wanna educate it I
want to educate it not only my family
but my fans as you know I have a lot
millions of fans probably for the future
I want to do it some book but not the
type of book I've got a good idea for
you on that yeah I told you it's a good
one but to help people how to be
how to maintain longevity and also I
think in your case how to survive life
right it's a lot of people out there who
are struggling to just deal with life
and the one thing you do better than
anybody I've seen in sport
is resilience
mental strength right that's what it's
really I think it's the most important
thing and I can see me in the future of
course I'm I want to improve my English
it's very good it's much better even
than last time I interviewed yeah but I
have to improve I have to do more
interviews I have to improve I know and
I'm I'm I I I want to improve
and I see myself to do it when I'm
retired to speak from
millions of people
advices yeah how to be a professional
player how to maintain your longevity
how
I'm not psychologist but I passed
through many many things and I can you
know about this above all how to win how
to win which is the most important I
think it's what it's all about I have
experience to
to expire people
for that I think I'm I'm a role model
and I I can help many many people in
that way if they want my help if I want
to listen to it right for sure
especially the young people I want to be
with the young people to speak with them
not only for them but for the Fathers as
well to put him in a in the right spot
Cristiano what a pleasure thank you very
much indeed thank you very much peace
very pleasure for me thank you thank you
very much
Andy with a wink of course it did an
extraordinary interview with an
extraordinary footballer and an
extraordinary man did he change your
mind that's for you to decide one
thing's for sure he set the record
straight and he was most definitely
uncensored
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]